hello screen junkies I'm Dan Moreau from
movie fights and summer movie report on
screen junkies plus and this is my
spoiler review of Captain America Civil
War now this is the first one of these
that we've done on screen junkies is
because so many people want to talk
about this movie what we liked what we
didn't like we're gonna break it down
right here now just a reminder this is a
spoiler review of the movie if you're
interested in hearing what I thought
about the movie without any spoilers you
can check my spoiler free review right
now on screen junkies comm so final
warning this will be a spoiler review of
the movie as we break down Captain
America Civil War
now I think the first thing that you
have to do when you're breaking down
Captain America's Civil War is focused
on the two performances that are at the
heart of this movie Chris Evans is
Captain America and Robert Downey jr. as
Tony Stark / iron man I think they both
crush it in this movie he's my friend so
was I you can't really tear two
characters apart that you haven't seen
together and over the course of 12
movies we've seen Iron Man and Captain
America build their bonds build their
friendship build their characters
together so to see these two friends
going head-to-head and it is a brutal
fight at times is really affecting
because we have that depth of character
history to build on now the one big
reveal moment that a lot of people have
talked about is the reveal that not only
did the Winter Soldier kill Tony Stark's
parents but the Captain America knew
about it all along I've talked to a lot
of people have said that that seemed
like he came out of nowhere that Captain
America knew about Tony Stark's parents
but that's actually not true I went back
and looked at the Winter Soldier again
and you see the moment in that movie
when cap finds out that's impossible
children stopped you accidents will
happen now is this beat a little rushed
in the movie yes it is but what makes it
impactful is that you see the pain
behind Tony Stark's eyes when it's
revealed and the reason that you buy
that pain is because we've seen all the
way going back even to Iron Man to what
the effect of Tony Stark losing his
parents has had on himself has had on
his character has had on the man that he
has become my greatest creation
is you it is a real testament to how
building storylines and plot lines over
movies over several years doesn't have
to be tedious it doesn't have to feel
cheap it can actually pay off in
unexpected ways
later on down the road now the other big
element that everybody wants to know
about in this movie is spider-man and
Tom Hollands performance of spider-man
and I have to say my favorite moment in
the movie and I think it says so much
about the character of spider-man is
when he's sitting and talking with Tony
Stark and he says something to the
effect of when you have powers like mine
and you don't do something when
something happens it's your fault that
says more about spider-man that says
more about what drives spider-man then
five origin stories possibly could
superheroes are modern mythology we all
know their origin stories we don't need
to see them on screen and with that one
line it's established that this Spider
Man has that same kind of pain in this
past he has that same kind of Drive in
his past and he integrates into the
group beautifully I love seeing him
jumping into the big superhero fight in
the middle of the movie and I personally
cannot wait to see him get his own movie
maybe finally spider-man might be back
on the right track in Marvel's hands so
let's talk about the three major new
characters that were introduced in the
movie first of all as we've discussed
spider-man
I liked him in the movie but I feel like
his introduction felt the tiniest bit
force but that's to be expected because
they had no other option they literally
could not put him in any other movies
before this one however the character
that I do think would have benefited
being in another movie before Civil War
is Zemo played by Daniel Bruhl we find
out through action that his plan is
completely driven by the death of his
family and the sokovia disaster which is
a great motivation however I think it
would have been a lot more powerful if
Zemo had been introduced in age of
Ultron if the Russos maybe it had a
little more interaction on Ultron or
maybe if they've been able to plan out a
little more ahead in Ultron instead of
sending Thor on his Jacuzzi sidequest
and put Zemo into the sokovia scenes it
would have flowed a little bit better
from Ultron to Civil War having said
that I thought Daniel Bruhl gave a
fantastic performance he was using
psychology as a weapon not brute
strength and I like that I like that not
every
villains plan is to unleash an army of
something we've seen too much of that in
the Marvel movies more than any other
movie civil war is a deeply personal
movie it's about these characters
personal vendettas with each other with
their past and how they battle each
other and try to reconcile it is at its
heart about a very personal clash
between friends and I think that's what
sets the war apart in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Canon all right now I
just want to do some quick hits on a
bunch of stuff that I don't have time to
go into in depth but that I really
enjoyed and liked about the movie number
one was Black Panther played by chadwick
boseman I am so excited for the Black
Panther movie right now and based on
where they left Bucky how awesome would
a Black Panther Winter Soldier mercenary
movie be set in Wakanda that might not
be where they're going but that would be
a really kick-ass movie secondly Thor in
The Hulk I didn't miss them I have to be
honest and I love the fact that they use
that in the movie when Secretary of
State Ross said if the US military was
missing a thermonuclear warhead don't
you think people would be upset about it
the fact that they didn't fold them into
the story I think worked for the story
they were able to address it
satisfactorily and I like the fact that
they were not missed and that they're
free to go do their own standalone
adventures all of which I'm sure we'll
see in Thor Ragnarok thirdly the
oscar-winner girlfriend game of phone
tag continues as Pepper Potts does not
make an appearance in this movie well I
guess the cut in the four twineth
Paltrow I get it but I also feel like
pepper deserved better
I hope that there are more chances for
her to be folded back into the MCU and
finally I'd be remiss if I didn't
address the actual civil war that's
happening right now the war seemingly
between Marvel fans and DC fans Batman V
Superman vs. Civil War in a perfect
world I don't think that these movies
should be pitted against each other I
think that they should exist in a vacuum
but people do compare them and they
actually are shockingly similar movies I
did not enjoy that and be Superman very
much and i like Civil War more why
personally I believe that the beats that
didn't work in Batman V Superman work in
Civil War because they've been
cultivated over time if Civil War had
been the second MCU movie I believe that
it would have been a mess it would have
been over stuff because we wouldn't have
had any setup for any of the
the shorthand that we have with these
characters over the past eight years is
one of the things that I think makes
Civil War work and the fact that you
didn't have that shorthand in Batman V
Superman is what I feel like makes some
of that movie not work but here's the
bottom line it's okay if you liked
Batman V Superman it didn't like this
movie it's okay if you like this movie
it doesn't like Batman V Superman it's
okay if you loved both movies it's okay
if you hated both movies this is
supposed to be fun we're supposed to be
having a good time the fans of volcano
and the fans of Dante's Peak didn't dock
see each other and yell at each other on
the internet because they disagreed they
just decided they liked one or both or
neither of those movies and that's what
it should all be about for the first
time ever movies are being made for
comic book fans of all ages of all
tastes and instead of letting our
differences divide us I think we should
get together and celebrate this
phenomenal time that we're living in so
as I close out this review of Civil War
I just like to say don't attack each
other over differences and superheroes
because you like one more than the other
these are supposed to be fun and we're
supposed to have fun at the movies I had
a lot of fun with Civil War I hope you
did too but if you didn't that's okay
thank you so much for checking out my
first review and if you want to hear
more from me you can check out my new
show summer movie report with Dan
Morelle I'm on every Monday wide at
11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time on
screen junkies plus what did you think
of Civil War do you agree with me do you
disagree with me let us know in the
comments below share subscribe check me
out on the summer movie report and
please keep going to the movies hi i'm
dan moreau host of summer movie report
with dan moreau on screen junkies plus
asking you to join me and my co-host
sasha pearl raver every Monday morning
at 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time as
we break down the summer box office
review the latest releases and tell you
what you should be watching all summer
so please join us right here each and
every Monday only on screen junkies plus
you